then someone start to touch me and then
men handle me like touching me
everywhere and then they start to cut
open my clothes with
scissors stripped me naked completely
except for my blindfold and my
earplugs they start to put me in diapers
and then
it dawned on me that i was not going
home i was going to prison
what does it feel like to have a movie
made about your life
it's it's really like so
like amazing and
i still i'm still digesting because
this is not in my wildest dream i didn't
dream i would have
like a movie you know about me i mean
how many people have
a movie about their lives you know i
don't know too many people
you know i don't know anyone in person
you know or in my surrounding and it's
just
a very big blessing to have your story
tall
on the big screen and to reach this
big audience especially in our world now
and it's not just
any movie right it's benedict
cumberbatch and tamir rahim and jody
foster
and then you were contributing to the
set design and the production
and all sorts this is a level right
a-list stuff
absolutely and i mean kevin
also kevin won oscars before
and yes and i was involved
i mean i didn't push myself on anyone
she just kept calling me and asking me
questions and i just kept like
answering them and
yeah like you said said also like
i also coached tahar rahim on the accent
and so on and so forth it was it was a
lot of fun
and pain at the same time how accurate
would you say the movie is
to what happened
i mean what we see in the movie is
pretty accurate
no except like chris you cannot put on
screen like
the first 70 days of sleeplessness you
cannot put that on the screen because
you just need an actor who stays sleep
without sleep for 70 days consecutive
days and that's very painful
take us through your story then why has
a mauritanian man
had a movie made about his life
uh so this starts with very
innocent phone call it was like
in late 98 or early 99 i don't remember
you know because i only knew about the
call
years later so and my cousin called me
and actually it was like very innocent
call he
asked me to wire some money to his
father
who was very sick in mauritania and then
i lived in germany
it was very easy for me and of course i
said yeah of course i would do that no
problem
and but there was a problem with the
call
so the call was made from the
uh from a phone that belonged to ubl
and my cousin was a friend of ub
i mean they found years later that he
was not involved
in the atrocious attack against
the united states on 9 11 but still back
then this was before 9 11.
and everything i did after that
was interpreted as a as a vile act
against the united states of america
everything i said was
interpreted in that way that i was quote
unquote a bad
guy and unbeknownst to me
i was you know subject to so many
investigations that i didn't know about
and then all the investigation done in
germany
and in canada they found out that
there was no evidence i did really
something
and then
i was so scared when our imam that is
our priest in the mosque
when he told me that the german police
some kind of police like very high level
police
you know like they came to me and they
showed him my picture and then
he laughed he said what do you want to
know about this guy they said
yeah we have some bad report that he is
he's a bad guy he was like he said no no
i know him in person he's a very good
guy he wouldn't hurt a fly
they said that's what we think too but
there is a country
a country that thing that is about he
told me that and i just
i just panicked i said i cannot stay in
this country so
and i had already my my
landed immigrant status in canada and i
moved i said when i moved to canada
fresh start no one knows me nothing i
would you know
finish college find job not fair i
already finished college but i want to
study
like phd and
that's it that's what i did and i was it
was so dumb because
i didn't know that the intelligence you
know agencies were so
like connected and canada was
very close to the united states so
going there just proved the point of the
united states that
i was a bad guy i was coming to canada
and as luck had it
i one month after my arrival about one
month
a guy decided to cross the border by the
name of ahmad rasam
and kill innocent people his name is
ahmad rasa
and he was go he they they said
on the note that he went to the same
mask i did
and he's all like pointed toward my
person
you know and then i don't know whether
you saw this movie
very old movie called a man with one red
shoe
by by uh
yeah i see his name against the guy
you know cast away
tom hanks yeah tom hanks so he
he was you know he was like expected of
being
a russian agent and then everything was
he was doing was interpreted that way
and it was very funny
so and then canadian
came to my house trying to try to
find out what was the deal they couldn't
find anything but
usa this guy is too smart he doesn't
leave any
we need to lure him to a place where
there is no law no rules no gloves
and then we can get our way with him
then they called my country the
intelligence of my country they told
them
how can we get him back to mauritian
and then they went to my family to my
mother
they said they should call him back your
son is in big trouble and
we need he needs to come back so we
clear his name
she called me and she said she was sick
that was january of 2000
and i just start like you know making
arrangement
i bought my ticket everything and i had
the feeling
you know i will be very exposed but
you know i think we are driven
a lot by emotions you know like
i tell you an example because i think
i'm a very
like reasonable person i'm a person of
reason
you know i believe in science everything
even though like i'm
a religious person at the same time kind
of
you know but sometimes
emotion emotions overwhelming
and the other day like
several weeks ago they called me they
said your sister
has covey 90
and then i i said
covered nine and then i i said i want to
visit her the doctor
said you cannot visit her so this is
like
stupid and then
because it's so dangerous and then i
went and then i bought some like
fruits everything and i went anywhere to
visit my sister
and then in midways i was like crying in
my
in my heart saying this is my sister
what what use of me being so healthy if
my sister
is so sick and this is so like
so like emotional and kind of stupid too
but i like willingly
risk this very dangerous like sickness
to see my sister and to be beside her
and show her life
the support you know of course i
took precautions put the mask everything
and but but i'm just showing you
that i went you know and i know there
was a risk
but this was my mother who called me she
is sick
that was picked up in dakar i was
interrogated for five days
senegalese said there is no evidence
against this guy
we cannot hold him so you need i said
i'm going back to canada
i knew i'm going to be screwed really
bad so i said i'm going back to canada
the u.s said no you cannot go back to
canada and they
forced me into a plane so now senegal is
like not
so it was like more cooperating with
them
they said you are not going back to
canada but they took my passport
they put you on a special plane and then
sent me to mauritania
i was interrogated for about one month
you know and then mauritanian came back
to the i said there is no evidence
against this guy
so he what should we do
and then they said release him but
he cannot leave the country so later
they took my passport my papers
and i said you know what i'm just going
to
not survive because we have we cling to
life so much
you know like no matter like if you get
abused
you still want to live if you get like
i just you know we just tried to use our
resources and
i was like highly educated and i found a
job
and i said you know maybe one day they
will
find out i didn't do anything to them
they would let
go you know and i was like working
long hours you know and barely making
the ends
meet you know this was like late 2000
and it
the there was this like bubble burst i
think from
iit and
and we just we didn't do well the
company you know went down everything
and i went to another company
and 9 11 happened you know 9 11 up that
was really
really bad time and
i was kidnapped i was put in a plane
by special team some of whom jordanians
i know that because they spoke to me
and then some were in masks
two were in mass i couldn't know who
they were
so and this was with the
collaboration and conspiracy of my own
government
in violation of the constitution
that foresees that no citizen can be
overhanded to another country
not to mention innocent citizens
at least there is no like evidence
against them
i mean to cut them some slacks and
yeah and i saw death so many times
i remember the plane landing in cyprus
i heard it in over the phone
and i was wishing and hoping
some custom agent or something bore the
plane
and see me and i would say i am i am
guilty i am guilty please arrest me or
listen
you know and but no one
no one shows up you know i felt death so
many times and
i wasn't you know i'm afraid of that but
i'm more afraid of dying itself
you know you know you know like
believing and after life and
the possibility that your afterlife
wouldn't be as good
it's very like scary things but dying
because i saw my
my my
the uncle of my mother i don't know that
what that
called in english you know
and i saw him die you know he's very
strong when he was a teacher
and i saw him withering away getting
weaker
and weaker and he couldn't take care of
his own business he was a very proud man
and then he started to smell because he
couldn't take shower
you know and i saw that as a child
and this like was so i never forget that
so and i i was like picturing
how much torch is going to take for me
to pass
away to die and
the then i stayed in jordan for eight
months
horrific ma you know like i wasn't like
beaten
i was beaten only two times but like
just living in the fear the prospect of
torture
day in day out for eight months
it's really very heavy you know
and the problem like when they start
torture sessions
i could hear people like crying and so
and then it was just like someone
piercing your ears
then i start to to
plug my ears with my you know my hands
but
i hear louder when i plug my ears
because the brain
create these sounds horrific sounds
and i cannot describe to
living in pain how painful it is you
know
and there is no end and there is no
like no i remember the day
i was taken you know before i was put on
the plane
and i just came back from work
you know i was doing installation
in the presidency out of all places
they want to
revamp their network and they took our
company
so i was the engineer who was in charge
i came back it was ramadan ramadan
meaning fasting
month and i came back
4 p.m i think it was around 4.
only my mother was home like my sister's
brothers
only she and me and
cain you know in plain clothes
said you need to come with us
she told me muhammadu in whisper
they take you know why i said no they
said because of the tv you watch tv
she doesn't want me to be involved in
politics or discussion or anything
and then they took me i said no no it's
going to be all right i'm coming back
and then they took me and then i was
watching her at the rearview mirror
as she disappeared getting smaller and
smaller
and i never forget her holding the
prayer beats
frantically praying until i turned right
i never saw my mother again ever
and the thing that i never realized
i never appreciated the pain she wanted
she was going through
because i never had a son i only had son
like two years ago
ahmed and i cannot even imagine someone
taking ahmed away
from me and taking him away with no
reason
like this is not like canada or like
a western country a free country where
the police
has to show cause meaning they said we
are taking your son
because of one two three four this is
painful still but
one can understand that you are in a
society and the society has roles and
you have to respect the roles if you
want to live in the society
and but nothing like that same thing in
jordan
i was not allowed to see the red cross i
was not allowed to call my
embassy nothing i was under the total
mercy
of people who work in the darkness total
darkness
away from podcasts away from
internet away from tv
everything democracy dies in darkness
so after that they came to me one day
then one of the guards threw
a trash bag a black trash bag one of the
heavy duty
through the bean hall the bean hall is
prison parlance for a very small
window like
very small windows where you can barely
fit your hand
where they give you food and they close
and communicate with you the girls and
then they throw the
the trash bag inside myself and say
you're going home
chris i cannot describe to you my
feeling
it's i just start like crying
uncontrollably you know
just like a child i was in a hole
in a pit for eight months
of course i lost count because later on
i knew that i didn't know the days
anything even though i tried to keep
them and i lost like 10 days in all
and i don't know where they went and
and because sometimes i didn't know days
and nights
because i was put in the cellar
underground
and and i was saying
now what came to me
i was saying i was a pure person i was a
good person in prison
because there was no opportunity to do
bad things in prison
like bad thing i mean like bad mouthing
it's making like unsavory comments
like criticizing your mother's food and
so on and so forth
and i was like i felt i was close to god
you know and you know prison is like
death
but this is like another life but now
i'm going back to life how would i do
in life would i be still a good person
in real life
and then i i came and then
i went to the bathroom but i didn't want
to tell them i went to the bathroom
because i didn't want them to change
their minds so i
i didn't want to the bathroom i said
let's go
and now they put me in a plane to
mauritania and i will just take
go to the bathroom and do whatever i
want to do you know
i'm not going to screw this up i came
there they took me
all blindfolded and you cannot see
anything
and then they took off the blindfold
they start to give me back my belongings
like
my driver license some money i had
you know and id card
stuff like that and
and they told me to sign money
because they told me the control and i
was shaking like this
i couldn't like i couldn't control my
shaking
and then i i i took the pen and signed i
didn't count anything i just said
whatever i agree whatever because i'm
going home i don't care about anything
else
then i saw the date 31st of july 2000
so that's what it hit me that
i had another date in my head
and no i i saw 20th
but in my head it was 31st sorry
and then i know i wasn't really in my
right right state of mind and then they
took me and they laid me
on like a stretcher and then they pushed
me into a
into some kind of track because i could
feel the moving
and then i heard the after i don't know
maybe
30 minutes or so i had
the roaring of engines i know i was in
in in airport in some kind of airport
and i
i was just i was almost exploding
because i
i need to go to the bathroom really bad
so bad
and i was like it's so painful when you
need to go to the bathroom and you
cannot
and
they start to play music you know to
just to uh
to dumb down my hearing so i don't hear
them talking conversing
and i love the music really it was abdul
halim haven
it's very legendary egyptian thing
and it felt like i'm back to life
i'm back to life and then
it took a long time i don't know
at least one hour at least
if not hours i don't remember but very
long time
and then someone start to touch me
and then you know like you know
men handle me like touching me
everywhere and then they start to cut
open my clothes with
scissors stripped me naked completely
except for my blindfold and my earplugs
he started to put me in diapers
and then it dawned on me that
i was not going home you know
i was going to prison very bad prison
life
and it came back to me those like movies
and those
like documentaries i watched in germany
about
uh rough american prisons
and i was telling myself i'm not going
back this
is it this is like i'm going to die in a
prison
in the u.s i'm going to be forgotten
you know i'm from africa this is bad for
me
i'm in arab which is very bad and i'm a
muslim
three strikes i could count in my head
and i wouldn't be treated fairly
and i was aware of the anger too of the
united states
and i just was like praying that my
family doesn't see me
ever on tv paraded in chains
you know because that would hurt them so
badly
and then i took it upon myself from that
moment on
if for some like miracle
if i go back to life i will be a good
person
why because i start to regret
what i did in my life because that was
like
a moment that i was living life and the
only thing i regretted
is not being nice enough why did i
criticize my mother
when i didn't like the food why did i
make this comment
you know why wasn't i nice why was i
courteous
to people enough and
i took it upon myself to be nice
actually i never like
regretted not having money i never
regretted not having this very hard
chick
i never regret any of that i never get
not having a house
none of that it didn't matter to me what
mattered to me
why didn't why wasn't i nice because
nice you don't need money to be nice
you don't need wealth you don't need
anything you don't need a look
you don't need a background to be nice
just
be nice you know and
a lot of people like ask me like oh you
said you forgave people everything this
is
a bunch of bs because i wouldn't forgive
people
but i would say you didn't have my life
because
to me i know what matters you know and
i'm doing myself a favor
you don't know how much favor i'm doing
myself and how
like selfish i am you know you don't
know how selfish i'm
very much you know
serving my own interest when i say i
forgive people
you know because i want to be a nice
person and to be honest to you know like
chris you know
you know i like tony robbins
you know i like his speeches a lot and
so
motivational speaker from the earth i
read his book everything
and some of the good thing he said
that stuck with me that your biography
biography does not dictate your future
you know like you know you can always
have if you the future you want
and this is all like easier said than
done you know
it's very easy like for you and me to
say i i
i want to be a nice person and i will be
a nice person it's not easy
because like circumstances like
keep keep pushing your button all the
time
and they have always to center yourself
come back said
how can i be nice without hurting myself
you know because that's like the
threshold
and so they put me in this diaper
and they took me out
and they put me in clothes
after that they took me out they
stretched me
on a stretch in a plane the plane
started to move
took off you know you know that by your
ears on the
crack pop
i was you know just like feeling so bad
for myself
you know
you know why why this is happening you
know i
i just i don't know what was going
through my head
but i want to pee so bad
and the diaper are for peeing but i
couldn't be
in diabetes i couldn't this is not
like you know i say something i say
uh subconscious [ __ ]
you know because with the way we were
raised
you know has so much bearing
and it's almost like a burden
you know on us you know i was always
like
you know the way i will raise it's not
you have always to be very private when
you
want to pee you have to be away from
people
you have to be in certain place to do
that
you know and now i know this
this does not work because i have to be
but i couldn't
the plane kept flying flying flying
fly fly you know
and they kept like to make it worse they
kept like
you know like sprinkling some how water
in my
mouth because they want to keep me
hydrated
now this is like kidnapping team they
know what they were doing
i was not their first client so and
they were not rough with me they did not
beat me
they did not treat me rough
even the guy who was like giving me
water he was just like
tapping like nicely on my shoulder
like first time like i i feel that
someone
is feeling my pain somehow but there is
no talking
and
i'm there is something in me
you know and i say we share this with
you chris that
just it dawned on me that i'm very
easily subdued
like a normal person would say
guys i need to pee but i never said that
no i was like mesmerized
in this world of silence and darkness
you know i couldn't see anything it was
total darkness
and no one was talking
and then i was completely integrated in
this like
very weird world and i accepted it
to my own detriment you know
and then i was just dying you know
and then
because you know when you start like
treating people
in this way like
this is not even didn't start torture
but we are very vulnerable
i'm saying this because later on i
learned that two detainees
died two i know of die on record
and so i think after five
hours or six hours i don't know
i was just in my head plain start to
lose altitude
you know i could i could feel that
my whole body could feel her
then he touched down
and then i was taken and then i was put
in a
chopper i know that because
i heard like it was so loud and
the way you know it must be a chopper so
there was no other way and then
they put me in a truck
truck was good because they sat me and
then
two people pushed against me and i felt
the worth of a human being
in a very long time eight months the
first time i feel the warmth of young
and i was so cold and then they spoke a
language i never heard
i started hearing them because they
spoke very loudly
this was like some of the afghani
languages that i was not familiar with
and then i thought but it was a philip
philippines
because i don't know just in my head i
said i know there is
the word like military base in philippi
i was thinking that i was going to land
in germany
ramstein and then taken
but this was not german language because
i understand german
obviously because i studied in germany
so and then i said this is philippines
so and then they took me and then they
they set me on my knees
and then for the first time
in a long time i peed like
a champion because i felt alone
and when i peed you know
i was a free man i didn't care about
where i was i didn't care what happened
to me
just the relief of the pain
that's just like giving birth
you know after a very long labor
and they start like to strip me naked
and then they took the
blindfold you know like your instinct
when they strip you naked
you always put your hands on your
private parts automatically
you know and then they start to
you know the weirdest thing that i saw
like they come to me and then they pull
my hair you know later on i
i understand this for dna testing
and so
and they start interrogation like
you know put me back in the blindfold
and then they start interrogation like
destroying chairs beside me
very loud you know just like in movies
no but they didn't beat me they just
like were asking me stupid question
because
they were not briefed properly who i was
and where i came from that i think the
cia plans just dropped me
and then they were like a lot of
different agencies and private
contractors
and everyone like everyone wants a piece
of you everyone wants to be the
the guy who is like
cracking the bad terrorist quote unquote
and because they were asking about bin
laden where he was
and where mullah omar mulamar is the
last president
of afghanistan afghanistan
and i didn't know there was a war
i didn't know they talk over kabul
i didn't i didn't know none of that but
they are questioning just give me
information
after information i just like watching
the bbc
so where did they go because they
thought i was
picked up from the battlefield that's to
the
they must have saw that i was saying
what i don't know i swear i don't know
just very broken no resistance nothing
they took me to this room
very alone like with carpet
one room and then they took me to
another one
and
i
i saw
i i don't know how but i saw the defeat
of a detained moving and i was oh my god
this guy being
tortured i'm sure you know
you know just like crazy stuff coming to
my head
and then there was no bathroom in the
cell so i peed
on the floor everything on the floor
and
they took me for
interrogation again must
have been nigh you know those like
people is makeshift prison
in bagram
you know but you know americans like
they always like
wherever they go they build this little
america right away
so i could hear like rock and roll
music you know people talking very loud
you know and eating all the time
all the time there is no like no break
you know some kind of like energy bars
you know or drink
there is no pause no not like sitting
there okay let's talk about something no
we have to eat something
and that's the first thing like that
came to my mind
and i was like very curious about amigos
i hear a lot about
americans i see a lot about americans on
tv or movies
you know but i never really met
americans no this was like mine
so they set me there there was this very
young
arabic translator you know she is
native born american you know i could
tell from the accent
she is not a native arab speaker
obviously
and then she asked me what languages do
you speak
it's a standard question because they
want to
organize their resources
i said i said and then i said like
german
french and so everybody was what
i said yeah i said they said first lie
and then they call the guy cia guy by
the name
name of misha il german
america then
he starts you know he starts speaking
german with me and
i responded him and he told them he
speak better
than i so my english was not good enough
to
carry on in interrogation it was very
basic
yes no and so on and then he told me
one thing i never forget he look at me
and say
fry height marked fry
nine var height marked fry bar height
meaning the truth will set you free
when he said that i had this picture he
called in my head
arbite fry
work will set you free and i never
forget this sign because i saw
it in german documentaries everything
over and over and over
and i knew the people
for whom this sign was meant did not
did not go fly free i mean
he never they they died actually and
that was like a very bad home for me
and i didn't say anything they assigned
me to him he was a very nice guy you
know
like nice for the circumstances because
when you say nice or bad
it's always compared to something else
because the first thing he did to me
say give me your password
that that the friendliest thing that
they could tell you they come
take you chris to the police said
you are on instagram you are on
youtube i need your password i need to
see everything you have
you would be like what who who are you
and then i told him you know to be
honest
i know i will end up giving you my
password i know there is no way around
it
and i also as a as a nighty person
i also know they have way to see
everything without me giving them my
password back then i was yahoo
email you know and i said
i start to get you know to get him on my
side i said you know this is a
you know against the law this is my
problem he said look
i give you two options either you give
it to me or i take it by
force and i said okay
then i wrote him my password
you know my password is very easy first
name of
my wife followed by her birthday
very easy and i never had like a
strong password anything because there
was nothing interesting in my
email or anything you know but it's so
painful you know to see your like
privacy
violated you know and there is nothing
you can do
this is like mundane to a lot of people
but
to me it's not mundane that someone like
tells you this this is like just if
someone tells you chris take off your
clothes
and they would say no i won't and they
force you to take off your clothes
because this is your privacy this is
your
home this is the door closed
but anyway then he start explaining to
me
the process and he told me one thing he
said
you are guilty even if you are not
guilty because there is no way out of
this he said
so make peace he said with that
and he also told me that i was going to
be
taken to guantanamo bay which i didn't
know
and he explained
when i was so happy because this is like
he said it's under american control
and i want to be under american control
because
i grew up when i was younger i used to
watch
law and order and
and married with children so
americans are funny and american respect
the rule of law
so i was not afraid that they would find
out anything against me because
i didn't do anything to them they took
me to guantanamo bay
and like first
about nine months it was like
interrogated it was very painful like
but i was not heavily tortured or
anything
but they decided
i was really i
really need to talk to them they thought
to confess to something
you put me on this like enhanced
interrogation technique euphemism for
torture
and starting from may of
2003 i was officially
enrolled in the program
and it was really painful
like no sleeping
you know and
interrogation 24 7 sexual assault
on three occasions at least i remember
i was beating until i broke my ribs
this all on record and
my gallbladder was destroyed
later on they had to take me to the
hospital
and remove it
and i was just a mess i was just a mess
but chris when they see this
all didn't like quote unquote break
they one day they came to me before the
boat ride
the infamous boat where they took me in
a boat and
you know drowned me and
and beat me all kind of beating
they came to me and said we are going to
arrest your mother
put her in man only prison
and there is nothing we can do if she
get assaulted then
and then i lost it i i said i was like
whatever i want i will and there is no
limit
no limit to my to what i would
confess and then
they like coached me
you know they said like let's say you
would
make an
an attack against cn tower
because they want to make it logical
with the time
because i was in canada and i never
heard of sian tower by the way
with all due respect and i never been to
toronto
in my life i said yes
then i start writing and they said you
need to write and i wrote it
i put the names of my friend as my
accomplices
he said you need to sign it and i did
sign it
and this was like so
like weird because they want to put me
on
death put me to death they need very
solid like confession
because i was the first candidate for
that penalty
and the guy came back to me start like
her sergeant first sergeant
shelley came to me he said
you know you are a good guy because you
confessed everything
you can negotiate like 30 years and so
and i was like listening i mean
i mean what world i was thinking what
world does he live in you know
and and like he was like giving me the
good news
the good news to him is me staying in
prison for 30 years
instead of being put to there and i was
just like mechanically
just saying with my ideas thank you so
much thank you
and he was saying how in america they
respect people who confess
everything and i was like yes yes
and then after all these
biggest challenge this is the irony that
my confession was
very big challenge to the intelligence
community
because it contradicted like
everything they know
they know i didn't do anything they just
wanted me there to give them information
about my cousin about people i know
about
about people who go to the mosque et
cetera
and they never thought i did like
i plan to attack like at least the cia
knows that
i didn't do that and the fbi they just
the guy who was
lead investigating millennium plot
we just told canadian press la presse
the other day
he said he went in person to guantanamo
bay
and told them muhammad has nothing to do
with the 9
with millennium plot you can
do something else because i know this
case because i'm
interrogating the guy the main guy
they have this obsession you know so
they know but the problem they don't
they don't exchange information so the
the the person who was like
interrogating me richard zully a cop
from
chicago he was
a private contractor he was working you
know
he was he was a private contractor
hired by dod you know
that is the the
the fells department
of defense so like the military
you know and he just wanted results
turned out he was a very bad cop indeed
because
he put innocent people behind bar some
of whom
20 years who turned out to be innocent
so that's his you know his magic
that he could break up like
innocent people and make them confess
something they don't put them in prison
so he was not important to the cia to
share with him information or the fbi
so and i was not important to the cio or
the fbi
to save me and said hey this is innocent
guy what what you do
so it was not important to them
so and then they they came back to him
they said
this is bs you know i says he didn't do
this
and he almost went crazy and
he he came back to me said they wanted
you to make like
a lie detector test and
i was so scared because i know how it
works
i said but when i do it the confession
will go
a waste because i cannot lie on
and then he said no no no okay okay just
you know he was like very upset but he
said no no you just
take just give the answers truth
and then i said okay they put me on this
like my detector and i cured myself 100
percent
and i passed i said i didn't do anything
i never done anything
i never thought about doing anything
against you
and dislike put a hold
on my case like forever
so they never took me out of torture but
they start like
tapering it i was going to ask how they
slowed down
from the enhanced interrogation back
into back into normal life before we
go on a little bit further i just want
to go back to the sleep deprivation how
do they deprive you of sleep during that
70-day
enhanced interrogation period
okay so
they have four shift three shift
of interrogation and they just take you
when the next shift uh when the this
shift is done they start and no
shift they take you out and
if you go back to yourself the time you
are in yourself they keep
banging on your door okay
the first 70 days was like that did not
stop
i after that i bought i lost
consciousness
and i don't know what happened in that
period
like two or three weeks i don't know
anything but they came back to sleep
deprivation
different technique they call it water
diet
they give me water every like about two
hours or one hour
they force me to drink like three
quarter of a liter
and then i keep just going to the
bathroom all the time
all the time no sleep and
i asked yoda one time why don't they
just like
keep me awake standing he said no it's
more painful
with water because you feel like
we are not we are not doing things but
you just cannot sleep you know
because giving you water is a good thing
so they make you
the architect of your own torture
correct
correct and he is right it's so painful
like every time you close your eyes you
want to go
to the bathroom and i developed
a very very
like
this habit very painful habit that
even though there is no water i keep
waking up during night
going to the bathroom sitting sometime
no water nothing
i don't want to be but just sitting
there
this took me many years you know in
prison
to get somehow under control and
now when i get depressed it comes back
to me right away
that i want to go to the bathroom the
first reaction
i want to go to the bathroom and
yeah feel free to interrupt me because
i'm going on
now i am
what's it like being sleep deprived for
70 days
you become a different person i mean
like
you live in a different world like
dimension
you are
just waiting to die kind of
and
i took sleep for granted like before
just so and now after that i understand
what when people in the pain
they cannot sleep a hundred percent
understand
you know how painful it is you know
we just need to sleep we just it's
we just need to take a break from like
working and
but just like i was just like almost
like an
animal i didn't even think about it i
just go to sleep that's
it i have like a magazine near my bed
or something to read you know that put
me to sleep
then i just go to sleep and then you
know
wake up in the morning fresh and so
happy
and but now i'm very conscious i said
now i'm going to sleep this is really
good thing
when i'm not depressed i feel
so good about it like the my favorite
place in the house
is my bed you know that's why i insist
to have a tv in my bedroom and this is a
big fight with my
wife because she doesn't want tv
but when she is not around i put back
the tv
but now she knows now she knows if she
watches this podcast she's going to know
that you're sneaking the tv back into
your bedroom
absolutely and i i i'm not going to be
controlled by anyone
you're not going to apologize um the
cells were kept really cold as well
right this was another another method to
try and
break spirit yes absolutely i mean there
are like
other technique like i didn't mention of
course because this was all
very well orchestrated and studied
like torture techniques
and i have to say you know chris
american people are not like that
american people are good people
they're very generous people you know
they're very uh
you know they have a lot of empathy and
they love people they love life they
love to live
you know we just we just there is
something i don't have any answer to
why do like good people
engage in very bad behavior
you know to get along and to go along
with other people
you know this is like human
like unfortunate is our nature whether
you are christian muslims
you know atheists buddhists or whatever
we know that
happens to all people they always engage
in horrific stuff
at least by omission or not like
reporting
you know and go along
and so they
you you were talking about the cauldron
the cauldron is really very painful
because i have only like
the the
prison uniform and overall
no two pieces sorry two pieces
and there is nothing under them nothing
light and they put me in this cold room
they crank up the ac that they have
there
and i just keep shaking
and i talk to ranika because i always
try to
negotiate my way out of torture
i tell them you are doing some bad thing
to me i didn't do anything
and then i told ranika you're killing me
who's sorry who's veronica
ranika is a navy lieutenant who was
a part of the team and she was like the
person who
who was like the nicest
in a way because she smiled sometimes
and you know
so i give you a very good wisdom if a
girl smile she's not going to give you
her number necessarily so
so she just smiled and i thought this is
a good person
i i said you are killing i'm dying
she said no you are not going to die
because we have doctors who have
everything
she was very wrong because you know
you know
died in the cold room
and and the dali war
died in the beating it took him only 24
hours
you know and he died
and because we are human beings we are
very
you know it takes so much to save one's
life but
so little to take out alive and this is
like
us was that lieutenant
the person who cried when someone came
in and took you out of the interrogation
room
there's a scene in the movie where one
of the interrogators who i think is a
female
another group come in and take you away
and this is for the mock execution which
i
i think i want you to get into is that
the lady the one that smiled at you
no that was mary she was also
you know
i mean she she participated in torture
and especially like sexual assault
but she was always confused
and she was not sure she was doing the
right thing
because she kept like talking to me said
you know what we don't give up because
this is like we don't care if the world
doesn't
like us but and then i know this is not
healthy for
us but we're doing it anyway so
she was very like conflicted you know
because she as if she was like trying to
convince herself she's doing the right
thing
and she came back
to me after this episode like you said
of
mark execution and waterboarding
it's
she came to me first they stopped her
because
that was a very bad behavior like to
them
like showing like any kind of
compassion compassion was
a red line but they brought her i don't
know how many months but they brought
her back
and she said she was so happy that
i cleared my name that
i she was really happy you know and she
watched with me a movie
called black hawk down she brought it
you know
just another movie showing american
greatness
and bravery and just the the right kind
of movies and
i was not actually watching the movie i
was watching the reaction
her reactions to the movie and that of
the gods
i just want to know
how this propaganda like
works on people you know like you know
you know a guy told me last night i was
invited to iftar an old
person a wise person from this country
he told me
he told me i need a mirror to see my
face
because my face is so close to me i
cannot see it without stepping back
and you know american people have
a lot to be proud of american people are
very inventive
they are the most powerful
country in the world and they never lost
a war in the last like i don't know
since the civil war
and yes
it's very it's very hard to
to see themselves as like just a regular
human being
and be down to earth everything you know
i'm a mauritanian and in mauritania we
think we are the best country in the
world
and you say mauritania no one knows what
mauritania is
let alone america so and i was watching
like blackhawk down
black hawk down is about american
uh soldiers in
in somali in somalia
and uh yes they just they showed that
they were fighting alone without anyone
helping them
people stabbing them in the back
and but the quiz that popped to my head
what are you doing in somalia this is
very far
from home so that but i couldn't say
anything i couldn't criticize
i just was watching and mary was telling
me look
look those brief people and
so you know those marine and everything
is nice
you know the the movie was the
cinematography was good
and american people look very handsome
very well dressed
and the pakistani guy who wouldn't give
them
uh assistance the bad guy
he didn't look good he had a very bad
accent he couldn't even speak
english you know this is all like you
know going
you know on the side of american people
you know the good people
you know the beautiful people you know
the well-dressed people the people who
go
everywhere to save freedom and
and i yeah that's why i was watching
uh staff sergeant mary and not the movie
just seeing if the hypocrisy was
registering on her face at any point
you said that i'm not going with that
that's fine because i'm
i'm british so i can say whatever i want
okay
you are the smart guy correct i know
that i heard
that some of the guards also suffered
from ptsd
after they'd worked at guantanamo bay
and obviously we're seeing the level of
conflict here some of the interrogators
some of the people that were looking
after you
even during the process they're being
conflicted
about their own motivations about why
they're doing what they're doing whether
they should be doing it
and that doesn't surprise me i remember
thinking afterwards
would i be able to would i be able to
willfully do something which after the
event would give me ptsd
but then i realized that's what war is
soldiers willfully go to war
that sometimes don't realize what
they're doing in the heat of the battle
and then afterwards that's when they
they pay for it and that's when the ptsd
comes and i can kind of see how that
would occur
with the guards but i can also see how
they would be conflicted as well
absolutely you know i remember this
young man
by the name of jedi his name is jeddah
he he came to me you know and he was a
good guy
and aside from participating in torture
and so
and he gave me cookies
you know no no not cookies muffin
muffin you know i remember this
blueberry muffin it's my favorite
and he he smuggled them to me
and this just comes to me and then he
just put them
open the bean hole and put them and go
away
then i take them and i ate them
and then he start it was forbidden to
talk to him
you know and then he came to me when
there was no one around
or when he's from always two guards like
watching me
all the time all the time light
doesn't go out so all the time
and
i just want your audience to appreciate
life
to appreciate like having a bedroom
and being able to put off the light
and no one is watching them they go to
the bathroom no one is watching them
they change their clothes no one is
watching them
everything i did was watch and recorded
for the future so american could take
out now
and put it on tv national tv
so and just thinking about it makes me
appreciate
life and appreciate privacy
and he came to me one day i told him
jeddah i want to ask you a question he
said
yeah i said why did you
force me why did you prevent you from
praying by force
and you know this is like you know you
are a christian and so
he said he told me yeah i know i'm going
to hell
but what do you want me to do i was like
but you are in a free country
you know your country you are a free man
like i understand if your dictatorship
but
he said yeah but if i don't do this job
they give me a shitty job
you know she says take me and this is a
good job
i don't know why it is good but i think
it pay pays more
i believe and then we end up
after my release he ended up
contacting contacting he he's the one
who initiated contact
all of the guards initiated contact i
never contacted anyone because
i i don't want them to think i'm trying
to
locate them or anything so all of the
gods
and like you said all of them were very
like
they showed contrition and they want
they apologize
to me and they
they they really hurting a lot you know
because it's just not normal that
you inflict pain on other people unless
you are very sick
and then you think you're gonna be free
after that i don't think unless you are
psychopath
you are going to suffer pain
the entry price to hell isn't that high
if all it is is the difference between
15 an hour and 30 dollars an hour that's
quite a cheap entry price to get
yourself into hell
committed to eternal domination for the
sake of 15
an hour i know i know you know it's
it's amazing but unfortunately like
like i said this is cross-cultural
phenomenon that
we as a human being and i know your show
concentrate on the big picture you know
how
and when we don't learn from each other
we cannot
grow you know and one of the good thing
one of the very big lesson you know i
was very like
local in my thinking you know i'm v
i'm going to be very upfront with you so
i thought okay
i am you know like look at us our
culture
muslim were the best people i'm in
africa
arab african best people and i always
looked at the interests of muslim and
era
but when i went to this painful
experience
the vast majority of people who stood by
me who showed compassion
are not muslims you know
they're christian they're jewish people
and their none with no denomination at
all and then i thought okay i need to
look at us as human beings instead of
force fitting people in
in very narrow identity you know because
i don't believe that if you say a muslim
this is
an identity that is like enough
description but muslim could be a man
could be a woman could be a liberal
could be a conservative
could be black could be white could be
feminist could be non-feminist
could be a european would be
non-european african
could be uh like and so on and so forth
i mean
so and so forth and when you start like
counting the thing that
that we share you and i as human being
even though we grow up in a very
different circumstances
it's we will find so many identities
that we share
you know that could like prevent
conflict
and promote understanding and peace
after the enhanced interrogations
finished and
the results of the lie detector test
came through
it turns out that they know now the us
government
know that you're not guilty you're held
for a further
nine years without charge you go through
this entire litigation process you
release your book
and then you eventually get out so not
only have you been through
before guantanamo all of this horrible
treatment at the hand of jordanians and
you're in cyprus and all of this other
stuff
you go through guantanamo you go through
the enhanced interrogation
then that's dragged out for nearly
another decade
then you finally get released how
is it that you don't have resentment
or hatred towards
that situation
you know chris i saw death
many times i faced that many times
and the only regret the only thing i
regretted
when i was about to die was not being
nice
you know that being right that's the
only thing i regretted
i didn't regret not having money i
didn't regret not
being in a bad ass not having money not
marrying this very hot girl
the only thing i regretted not being
nice
and i took it upon myself to be as nice
as nice as possible to people make a
difference
because that would make me happy and
that because everybody will die i mean
one day and i want i want to go
in peace and as a happy person i don't
want to have regret
when i'm on my deathbed and
today you know
i met you you know and
so i want you to have good memory about
me that's all i want
and i don't want fake memories i want
you to have good memories that
i can only think good thing about this
guy because we have in our tradition we
have a saying
say in hadith that the the
the saying of our prophet people decide
who go to heaven that's a saying
people decide to go to heaven
because their testimony are the one that
takes you to heaven
and i want good testimonies not fake not
faking like niceness
no i want to be nice because i give you
an example
people who hurt me the most one of the
prayers the most is
richard zuli a lieutenant from chicago
very known look him up you find it
he's an old man today very angry man
i don't want him to suffer because
nothing good is going to come out of
him suffering at all i won't get any
money
i won't get any status i don't get any
power
when he gets when he suffer and i
hate to see people suffering anyway and
you know there is this
girl i think she she is canadian
lebanese
and she said i forgive you not because
you deserve forgiveness
or you ask for forgiveness but because i
want to live in peace
and it's very hard to find forgiveness
in in for someone who hurt you so badly
and this is for everyone i mean look in
your life
look in your friend's life a very bad
breakup
someone who betrayed your trust this is
very hard to forgive you know
but when you come to term
you know with that and when you decide
to forgive
it's just so rewarding because
i mean people called me and people
you know are like ask me as if i was a
doctor because they want
me to help them heal
and this makes me really feel very good
and i tell you another thing which is a
little bit evil side
of me so there was this interrogator
she was so obsessed with my case you
know
the guard called call her tons of fun
because she was on the heavier side
of the scale and she was so obsessed
like with my case
and she always believed i'm a bad guy
and then this journalist asked me to to
talk to her
i said no problem and then she talks to
me
and then she said i just want you to
to answer one of my questions i said no
i don't have to answer any of your
question
this is not interrogation room he said
but
yeah you you are then you are not
innocent i said i'm not claiming
anything
i don't have to prove anything to you so
and
hair like you know
agitation really gives me some
like satisfaction because because
she she couldn't come with peace and i i
just want to be friend with her
and i want to move on but she wouldn't
she wouldn't
but after so many years in guantanamo
bay she wouldn't move forward
and i found out either way i will be
happy
if you are if you want to open your
heart and be my friend
i will be your friend if you want
to stuck in guantanamo bay it's fine
with me too
because like the journalist was saying
why don't you answer i said
because i don't want to i want to be in
charge
of when to give an answer and not to
give an answer and
she's her i told her
it's fine to think i'm a not a good guy
but as long as you don't torture me
that's fine with me
and today you are not going to torsten
because we
are 5 000 miles apart
kilometer kilometers about 3 000 miles
and it felt good honestly well you're
exercising your freedom
after all that time where you didn't
have your freedoms you weren't free to
choose your own actions and your own
agency
and you are i think even the most
virtuous amongst us are still at the
mercy of our biology
right we can't get rid of the desire for
a little bit of le retribution even if
it's a little snipe here and there
you know a verbal game whatever it might
be i have a friend who said
thinking about what you were talking
about there about the fact that your
captors some of them
couldn't release they couldn't
relinquish their anger and their
distaste
and he says that anger is like a virus
so it's been passed from person to
person someone was angry
and then they've displaced that anger
onto somebody else and they've displaced
that anger onto somebody else
and it takes an incredibly strong person
to be a bookend
you know to be the end of a bracket to
stop that
and to say i don't know who you got it
from and i don't know who gave it to you
and i don't know who gave it to them
but i'm not going to decide to pass it
on i'm going to be the end of this anger
so beautiful chris so beautiful i
learned very good lesson today
this is something i will not forget and
this is so helpful to know it
consciously
you know that you need to stop it either
because it's your responsibility like
paying it forward kind of this is
beautiful honestly
tell me about your situation now my
situation
so
i'm trying to pick up the pieces
and i'm trying to be happy
and i'm trying to help as many people as
possible
in my life you know paying it forward
i have on the civil side
i i'm married i have a child by the name
of ahmed he's two years old
my family lives in germany i'm still
trying to join them but
the stigma of guantanamo bay is still
like still like
chasing me and i'm trying to promote my
movie
and i was invited by benedict
cumberbatch
all of the crew but i couldn't attend
because the uk denied my visa
and this all the stigma of guantanamo
because they have this circular argument
if you had been to guantanamo bay
you must deserve to be in guantanamo bay
and i completely understand like that
the security forces like
in a democracy they have
the sacred job to protect the people
you know i understand that completely
and i understand that people commit
violence for many reasons one of them is
ideological reasons
but i just want the people in your
country
and in other words to understand that my
family
and my friends in mauritania they just
want the same thing that you want you
and your family want
they want better jobs better life
they want peace they want longer life
better
health care system that what we talk
about we don't sit and
think about how to hurt people we don't
know
in the united kingdom we don't think
about that
we understand you know we are
you are doing better than us you know
being a free country for a very long
time it's a very good thing
we still fight for the most basic
freedoms in this part of the world
and instead of
your leaders like encouraging
like authoritarian regimes we want
them to encourage more democracy more
freedom
so that we could be like
like you have the same freedom so i work
for that
the rest of my life i work for freedom
i don't want my son to be kidnapped i
don't want my son to be hurt
i want him to live a free life
you know where he could choose where to
go
what to do you know without fear from
retribution
because he has different opinion
or the government thinks that he's a bad
guy
i work a lot on human rights
and i do webinars
and i'm trying to be
you know just to lead like good life a
happy life
will coming everyone not caring about
political colors
or political ideologies
man the world is so much of a better
place for having you back in it
i adore your message i think that the
peace
and the wisdom and the serenity that you
bring to a situation
that's still cursed with all of the
stuff that you went through
is it's mind-blowing it's absolutely
mind-blowing and i
i want everybody that's listening to
think
about the challenges that they have in
their life and about the things that
they're resentful for
about their housemate that didn't take
the bins out
last night or about that guy that always
parks in their parking space at work or
my coffee's a little bit cold or
whatever it might be
you know these things or the people that
scorned them in the past
i have chips on my shoulder i still have
chips on my shoulder from teachers in
school or from
the way that other kids spoke to me or
all of this sort of stuff
if you are able to let go of the
situation and the experiences that
you've been through
there is no excuse for why someone like
me
living in the life that i have in the
country that i have
with the politics that we are fortunate
to have
you think about the politics think about
how how
vehement and aggressive and forthcoming
and self-righteous people are
in america and the uk about our our
political system about the fact that
someone wants a slightly different type
of
tax on companies income tax or business
tax to another person
and again we compare all of this with
what it is
that you went through the contrast
effect
is such a powerful incentive
when we're exposed to the best of
everybody else's life on the internet
and on social media every day
it's very easy to forget
the normal blessings that we have
the ability to go to the bathroom
without being watched the ability to go
to sleep in a dark room that's the right
temperature
your freedoms the fact that you can see
your family that you can see your mother
when you want how you want um
man the world's a significantly better
place for having you back in it and i'm
very very glad that you're here
thank you so much chris you are a very
lovely person
and your message is a mess a very
beautiful message
and i'm a better person for have having
talked to you today and having
been your guest and we're gonna see each
other
i'm going to go there and bring down the
house i love it man in a positive way
i love you exactly careful careful about
saying that okay um
god it started again uh the mauritanian
everybody needs to go and check it out
it is available
free to stream on amazon prime if you've
got it
also your book will be linked in the
show notes below
and this has been outstanding thank you
so much for your time today brother
i have another book that came out in uh
february by the name ahmed and zarga is
a novel a short novel about bedouin life
i'm going to send you the link
i love it and that's about camels right
yes yeah you know about it
and don't you worry i know about it i've
done my research man
i hope to see you in the uk very soon
thank you so much man
thank you thank you brother thank you
very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace
you